hi and welcome to cloud on air live
webinars hosted by Google cloud every
Tuesday my name is Elise Roche and I
work around data for social and
environmental impact at Google cloud and
today I'm here with Jenny Oldfield
director of communications from the
global partnership for sustainable
development data hi today we're here to
talk to you a bit about our work data
for good and how data analytics can be
leveraged for social impact as a quick
note you can ask questions throughout
the webinar on the platform as we do
have Googlers on standby to answer them
and we will be hosting a live Q&A at the
end of our presentation with that let's
get started so before we dive into our
work and some of the projects that were
working on specifically we would like to
rewind a little bit and talk about data
for good as a whole it's
interdisciplinary and it's international
it is a movement in the making private
companies are working with governmental
agencies NGOs and nonprofits to apply
big data solutions to the world's most
pressing issues from conservation to
crisis response to preserving
biodiversity data scientists analysts
designers and strategists are actually
all coming together to drive real world
impact at scale and here are just a few
highlights from the movement as well
starting in 2008 Google released an
experimental data analytics project
called Google Flu Trends which sought to
predict the extent of a flu outbreak
based on online searches so essentially
treating searches like flu symptoms or
at home remedies as a proxy for an
outbreak in a particular area in 2011
the UN global pulse initiative
introduced the term of data philanthropy
to describe a kind of collaboration
where private sector companies share
data for public benefit those who
actually have the financial resources
and also the infrastructure to collect
this data are able to then share it for
the public good and in 2013 the UN
demonstrate the potential of satellite
imagery to address crisis response to
analyze disaster areas and provide
emergency relief by comparing pre and
post disaster data so to actually pull
up yet one image and compare it to the
next and see who needs the most relief
as soon as possible in 2017 the UN
hosted the world's first world data form
where the statistical Commission agreed
that a forum would help to foster
cooperation across professional groups
in information technology data science
and civil society and actually the next
one is coming up in October in Dubai and
here we are in 2018 with the creation of
interdisciplinary programs that provide
nonprofit organizations with integrated
solutions from productivity tools to
planetary scale data sets plus there's a
collaboration between Google cloud and
organizations like the global
partnership for sustainable development
data so what is Google cloud doing
within this data for good movement so we
are looking to empower nonprofits with
integrated solutions from Google Earth
outreach and geospatial analysis to G
suite for nonprofits with collaboration
and productivity tools GCP public data
sets which allow really anyone to
analyze data to one terabyte per month
for free planetary scale data and most
recently data solutions for change a new
program that helps nonprofits achieve
their missions at scale with data
analytics so here is a snapshot of our
own time line for nonprofits and social
impact in 2007 we launched the Google
Earth outreach program with the Google
Earth team and Google Maps actually help
nonprofits access satellite imagery and
API is it's also worth noting that the
Google Earth team recently announced a
partnership with the UN Environment
Division which is quite exciting in 2011
G suite for nonprofits enabled
nonprofits to collaborate and innovate
together with productivity tools and
with free storage and in 2016 GCP public
datasets launched in order to
democratize access to planetary scale
data sets which are freely hosted in the
cloud so again anyone can query these
datasets up to one terabyte per month
for free
and these datasets include data from the
World Bank from the UN statistics
division the EPA the US Department of
Health and Human Service
is just to name a few and in 2018 as I
mentioned before we recently launched
the Data Solutions for change actually
just in July at our next conference in
San Francisco and we are looking to
empower nonprofits again to achieve
their missions at scale with data
analytics and with machine learning we
understand that with big data solutions
nonprofits can scale their data to
actually analyze data at the scale of
the entire web with bigquery to get to
terabytes and petabytes of large-scale
data analysis they can also automate
their work and tap into artificial
intelligence with cloud machine learning
it's particularly important as this then
allows you know nonprofits and their
team members to focus on their core work
and on their core mission as opposed to
you know manually analyzing whether it's
you know datasets are creating their own
models and they're also able to share
their vision to turn data into
customizable reports with Google Data
studio this is particularly important as
Google data studio directly connects to
bigquery so they're able to go from that
large-scale data analysis to custom and
interactive reports in minutes and in
crafting the data solutions for change
program we took into account two key
barriers that nonprofits face when
trying to complete advanced cloud
computing projects the first one being
financial in the second technical so
financial in the sense that it can be
difficult to you know muster up the
budget or Finance you know even a short
term data analytics project never mind a
long term data analytics project and the
second barrier being you know technical
expertise so actually giving nonprofits
the opportunity to learn more about GCP
as a whole and also learn more about
data analytics and machine learning
specifically so with the Data Solutions
for change program we're offering
nonprofits the opportunity to apply for
a Google cloud credit grant which is
need-based self training resources which
will allow them to develop that
knowledge of data warehousing and
machine learning with quick labs and
also hands-on support so again
addressing that point on technical
expertise and allowing them to get
advice on their architecture and also
resolve issues with Google
customer support it's worth noting that
data solutions for change is application
based and kind of it's it's similar to
an accelerator program in the sense that
each grant is six months so the grant
period has a duration of six months and
while we launched this in July of 2018
we've already been working with
nonprofit organizations and want to
share a few snapshots with you today so
the first one is the open agriculture
foundation they're using bigquery and
IOT core to create healthier more
engaging and more inventive food with
technology so they're actually creating
these contained environments that they
call food computers in order to better
understand how to optimize plant
production so to adjust variables like
nitrogen levels in the soil or humidity
in that contained environment to
understand what makes one plant more
productive than another given those
variables and then open sourcing that
plant code online to create a an
engaging food ecosystem next is the
Harambee youth employment accelerator
they're using bigquery and machine
learning to connect more unemployed
youth in South Africa with jobs taking
to account variables like location you
know where the applicants live in
relation to that prospective job and
also there's the foundation for
precision medicine they're using
bigquery and machine learning to detect
Alzheimer's early and stop the
progression of the disease that's
particularly important because
Alzheimer's has no cure so the
foundation for precision medicine is
approaching this particular challenge
thinking about preventative treatment so
getting ahead of a traditional diagnosis
months or even years in advance of when
they would usually do so and then that
will allow again for that preventative
treatment and with that would like to
actually share a video of the foundation
for precision medicine the work that
they're doing and how they're leveraging
data analytics and machine learning to
achieve their mission at scale
my name is Robert ABS and five and a
half years ago my mother was diagnosed
with Alzheimer's I knew none of the
medications were working the entire time
was a downward spiral and also lost my
grandfather about 25 years ago to the
disease my family at the time felt like
it was already too late to change the
trajectory of the disease and it breaks
my heart when I hear the same stories
today the mission for foundation for
precision medicine is to bring AI and
healthcare together to detect
Alzheimer's early if you can detect
Alzheimer's very early on that is when
the disease is most susceptible to
treatment the data of W have access to
our anonymized electronic healthcare
records we needed a HIPAA compliant
environment which is why we use google
cloud we're dealing with hundreds of
variables on millions of patients which
generate billions of lines of data who a
cloud enables us to scale our operations
and bigquery ml we were able to develop
machine learning models faster and
utilize our entire data being a
non-profit we rely on our volunteers
across the US and we'll out really
enabled us to do that we wanted them to
be able to apply machine learning on the
data and look at trends themselves to
empower them to come up with more
innovative approaches to change the
progression of the disease this work is
so important to me
because it helps us address this
devastating illness that has no cure I
heard somewhere that they said don't
forget that dots on the plot are people
and we really take that seriously
and that was a snapshot from the
foundation for precision medicine again
who are looking to leverage bigquery
machine learning to detect Alzheimer's
early and stop the progression of the
disease and in addition to the nonprofit
program that we launched Data Solutions
for change we also explored the
opportunity to inspire and engage the
next generation of data scientists
analysts and designers and that is a
data storytelling contest called
visualize 2030 data stories for the SDGs
or sustainable development goals which
Jennie will be talking a bit more during
her portion of the presentation so with
this contest we're asking students at
the university level so college or
graduate level students to use Google
Data studio to analyze data sets from
the UN statistics division and also from
the World Bank which we also migrated to
the GCP public data sets program to tell
a data story about how at least two of
the SDGs influenced each other and how
we can achieve them by 2030 and this is
for the chance to receive a $10,000 cash
prize and also announcement and
promotion by Google cloud as I mentioned
a bit earlier in the presentation on
data for good and the importance of
interdisciplinary partnerships we're not
doing this alone we are working with the
World Bank with the global partnership
for sustainable development data and
also the UN foundation to bring this
contest to life and with the global
partnership for sustainable development
data specifically we're actually working
with them across both data solutions for
change and visualize 2030 they're soon
to be a participant in the nonprofit
program and as I mentioned briefly
before we're working with them with the
contest as a whole as a partner so with
that I'd like to pass along to Jenni to
talk a bit about her work and the
projects that they are currently working
on hi there my name is Jenni I'm the
communications director at the global
partnership for sustainable development
data the name is too long so you see it
abbreviated there is GPS dd so
originally
Elle has given you some of the
background on you know how data came to
be more integral to the United Nations
but there's a little timeline here on
the slides just to go through that the
UN advisory group identified data as a
major driver for sustainable development
there was a report to the
secretary-general in 2014 called
a world that counts that really looked
at the different data communities and
identified the need to bring them
together and identified the need for an
organization to help bring those
partners together and therefore we were
created founded in 2015 in Addis Ababa
in Ethiopia and then launched in New
York so we're an initiative that's
housed at the United Nations Foundation
and that's because we really straddle
both worlds we work with UN agencies and
we work with all of the different
partners across private sector NGO
governments that are needed to bring
change together so we currently have 320
partners as of today based all over the
world and as I said across every sector
working together to achieve social
change and to achieve the sustainable
development goals
so just to recap on what the sustainable
development goals are they were brought
in in 2015 and they take us three to
2030 and they replace the Millennium
Development Goals which were somewhat
more simple but with less ways of
measuring them and less comprehensive in
terms of climate and resilience so the
first six sustainable development goals
that you see here are essentially the
sort of traditional indicators of
development progress so no poverty zero
hunger health and well-being so you know
eliminating diseases education for all
which there's been an enormous amount of
progress on thankfully gender equality
and clean water and sanitation so people
having access to clean water but this
expanded number of sustainable
development goals really reflects the
enormous progress that countries made in
agreeing with each other what's
important so the other sustained
development goals they cover energy they
cover decent work so not just having
enough work to live but also having
decent employment and protected rights
different industries working together
for the you know to harness innovation
for social good then reducing
inequalities because it doesn't matter
if a country is becoming more wealthy if
the people at the bottom aren't
experiencing any of those gains and the
rich are becoming rich or the poor are
becoming poorer also sustainable cities
and communities recognizing that we can
develop while still protecting the
environment and responsible consumption
climate action these these all speak to
a kind of tremendously impressive
agreement between countries to actually
try and protect the world which as you
know climate resilience is a big issue
so life below water and life on land
speak to protecting animals on land and
in the sea and then these final two are
important and really underpin progress
in all of the other sustainable
development goals so peace justice and
strong institutions speaks to the need
to have democratic societies and to
include people's voices within
democratic societies and then
partnership speaks to some of the things
we're talking about today which is the
need to bring people to the table so
there's no way that all of these
tremendously ambitious things can be
delivered without working across all
sectors and that's where we come in so
underpinning these 17 goals there are
around 200 indicators and the attempt is
to measure progress year-on-year
country on country to make sure that
we're headed in the right direction and
that's really where data comes in we
need to have a better appreciation of
whether we're actually making progress
and we need to harness innovation to
actually achieve all of these goals
otherwise we're essentially investing
money and things and having no idea
whether it's working or not so just to
explain a little as background how we
work we have a number of
governments that we work with there are
currently five in Africa and several in
Asia and Latin America where we work
deeply with them to really put in place
the building blocks of data for
sustainable development so that
encompasses everything from statistics
and the traditional measuring of
populations and progress through to
innovative methods this satellite data
that Elise referred to earlier and you
know kind of looking at how new sources
of data can be used as proxies for
development so we work with them to
identify what's working and then we
share the we share the learnings from
that with other countries and then we
bring in expertise from all of those
different sectors and the different
partners so this is really a unique
partnership in that it's very demand led
it's based on not coming up with a
solution and then trying to see who can
use it but asking countries what do you
need in order to make progress going and
finding it bringing in the best minds
and we like to say that we're applying
the world's best solutions to the
world's worst problems so the data
festival just to end that point was
bringing everybody together in the room
to discuss some of those things and make
sure that we really are learning the
best from you know all of those
different organizations across all of
those different countries so the
inclusive data charter is a project that
we launched in July and it specifically
speaks to data as an issue of social
justice so many people in this world you
know they're born they live their lives
they die without ever having been
recorded in any data and we think that
that's a tremendous shame because it
means that they are unlikely to receive
any kind of social benefits healthcare
education you know their births aren't
registered so we hope to help countries
capture their populations more
effectively and help charities and
others sort of serve different
populations so that we're sort of making
the invisible visible and in doing so
there's a kind of transparency dimension
to make sure that that these people
aren't overlooked
so the sorts of people I'm talking about
our women tend to be overlooked in data
different age groups you know the
elderly people who live in very rural
populations those are disabilities
ethnic minorities indigenous populations
and anyone who would be typically
marginalized in society so we have 10
different organizations working with us
on this and a number of governments and
they're focusing on different elements
of that inclusion so for example site
savers is an organization that is
focusing on disability data and how we
can better capture people within that in
order to help them data 2x focuses on
gender and UNFPA which is the UN agency
for population is looking at people in
remote locations and how we can use
geospatial sources to capture their
presence
so each organization has a different
Charter and then they share the results
of those and encourage other people to
join that movement another data solution
for change is the Africa regional data
cube and I think I'll pause now to show
you a video that says a little bit more
about it we're very excited about the
new African regional data cube it brings
this new data technology to five
different countries in Africa that
typically are not users of satellite
data and they're gonna have this chance
now to look at the earth from totally
new ways and to use it for sustainable
development goals initially data was
being siloed as a scientific tool but
what I've learned is data actually is an
everyday thing that should inform
transform and even inform how we do our
daily business from my own livelihood to
environment and policy and to re-engage
as networks with globally
we have all the data we want now but
that's actually a bit of a problem it's
no longer how do I get the data and I
can't buy it it's now I've got so much
data how do I use it if we can get this
analysis ready data in a form that these
countries can use it rapidly and
effectively we've removed a lot of that
burden because most of the problem they
had in the past was just pulling the
data together and making it useful how
much research is being blocked by the
fact that people just can't access the
data that they're trying to get when the
absence of data truly becomes very
difficult for us and as a developing
country to really effectively plan and I
think the government has taken it made a
deliberate decision to really leverage
innovation leverage ICT to make data
more readily available to support our
planning processes
earth observations both from satellites
as well as from ground-based stations in
situ data and data from airborne sensors
can help when combined with other
sources of data such as national
statistics administrative data and other
types of data sources including citizen
science crowd-sourced data can really
help countries monitor and understand
how to better monitor and achieve
progress toward sustainable development
in a consistent cost-effective and
timely manner through the Global
Partnership you are at the forefront of
the innovation and new ideas that will
bring the promise of the data revolution
to bear on the most critical problems of
our time and on our efforts to achieve
the SDGs I congratulate your progress so
far I'm particularly excited to see the
launch this week of the Africa regional
data cube which aims to increase
agricultural productivity and provide
jobs for young people we are especially
pleased that with the launch of the
African regional data cube that will
begin to make the benefits of data
revolution more real and tangible to
data communities who have often been
left behind this is a big step towards
the destination of who we want to be in
2030
[Music]
hi there so as you see from that video
it's a tremendously exciting project and
it brings together a number of different
organizations so five countries as it
says here on the slide along with NASA
who are sharing the data geo and others
and institutionally has at a university
in Kenya which is great so that we're
building expertise within the country
and within the region and the thing
about the Africa regional data cube is
that a number of different countries are
beginning to practice this open data
cube innovation which is really about
putting in place the infrastructure to
access this information easily and then
some of the different subjects that
they're interested in surfacing are
agriculture and food security
deforestation poverty mapping and also
the detection of illegal human activity
so illegal mining logging that sort of
stuff
so we're really expanding our knowledge
on the international stage about how we
can leverage this data to achieve those
sustainable development goals it's a
scale that we really haven't seen before
and then one of the areas that we're
learning about together is how this can
be integrated with different great data
on the ground so statistics and mapping
and in some cases citizen generated data
so this is really we're at the beginning
of a really exciting journey and we
think that this will be a massive help
in helping us achieve the sustainable
development goals so that thank you
Jenny and come together and join the
movement
so for data solutions for change if you
are an eligible nonprofit organization
and would like to learn more and apply
please visit cloud kugel comm slash data
- solutions - for - change and if you
are a student at the University level so
again college or graduate level and
you're actively enrolled would like to
learn more
and submit your data story please visit
cloud google.com slash visualize - 2030
and for the global partnership for
sustainable development data if you work
for an organization that you think could
get involved in this as a data producer
as a data user as a NGO or anyone
interested in achieving the Sustainable
Development Goals get in touch we're a
very open house and we're happy to talk
to you and explore what is possible no
matter where you are in the world thank
you absolutely so that's a wrap thank
you all for your time today and we will
be cutting - a live Q&A now and we'll be
back shortly
you
hello we're back with questions from the
audience so to begin the first question
is so one of the SDGs is global
partnerships was gpsed
founded in order to address that goal
specifically are there other
organizations whose mission is to
address one or more of the sustainable
development goals yeah thanks for the
question that's a great question so
there are numerous you know hundreds and
hundreds of organizations that are
created in order to achieve the
sustainable development goals or that
predominantly look to work towards
achieving the Sustainable Development
Goals and different UN agencies have
different interests so at the moment I'm
working with the Food and Agriculture
Organization the World Food Program and
the International Fund for agricultural
development on data connected to
sustainable agriculture so there's a
whole kind of ecosystem of people there
and then when you look at sort of UNICEF
and other agencies they're very
interested in health of course in
children and them having education so
there really is a huge ecosystem and
around each of those sustainable
development goals you have a very vast
number of organizations sort of working
together on partnerships to achieve that
so and there's also a number of
organizations that are focused on
specific partnerships in order to
achieve that so there are some that are
focused specifically on private sector
and public sector innovation there are
some that are focused on education
partnerships and so forth what mark says
out is really the sole focus on data and
how it can be leveraged to measure and
achieve the sustainable development
goals and really the fact that we're a
sort of a neutral convener in this space
so I think I mentioned earlier that
there are sort of different
constituencies within this community
some people are very interested in
transparency open data accountability
some people are interested in new
sources of data and how
can be leveraged for social good some
people's focus is primarily statistics
some people are interested in citizen
generally citizen generated data and how
people speak about their own reality and
then there's everything in between so we
really kind of look to span those
organizations we have different working
groups that focus on different elements
and then we bring together different
people to sort of get the best knowledge
out of our groups and to further our
common goals great so the next question
is what is the relationship between the
Millennium Development Goals and the
estimate geez how is success measured
and how our organization's approaching
the SDGs differently today that's a
really good great question as well the
Millennium Development Goals which ran
until 2015 were tremendously important
and a great endeavor but as I mentioned
earlier they weren't as comprehensive as
the sustainable development goals and
really the process through which
countries agreed on their common goals
for the sustainable development goals
they really looked at some of those gaps
predominantly gaps around climate
resilience which has sort of risen on
the agenda as were seeing more extreme
weather that was captured a lot more
also the sustainable development goals
were decided not by what were able to
measure necessarily but by the ambition
of what we need to achieve and then
looking at the gap between what we
currently have and where we can be so
the idea was to sort of future-proof
them for their kind of emergent
technologies and innovation and as you
saw with some of those projects like the
Africa regional data cube our kind of
knowledge and awareness of how we can
leverage this technology is coming on in
leaps and bounds so there's been an
enormous exercise currently we don't
have sustainable data for two-thirds of
the SDG indicators which is really
surprising and you know a difficult
situation so essentially we need to look
at those missing two-thirds look at how
we can capture them and look at how we
can be creative in
how we do that so that we can really
kind of superpower progress and as a
follow-up question to that if the GPS CD
organization or one of your partners
actually working to address that
information we got yeah there's been
several mapping exercises that have been
done by the UN system especially the UN
Statistics Department and they identify
some of those gaps and then we work with
our partners to try and kind of fill
some of those gaps and then also look at
the kind of potential beyond what is
just traditionally needed for monitoring
so there's there's a big exercise
underway from numerous different
partners to kind of do the monitoring
and one of the one of the mechanisms for
that is having countries stand on the
world stage at the high-level political
forum and kind of present on the
progress that they're making and how
they're measuring it and some countries
are more advanced in that and they're
more proud of their investment in doing
that and then we seek to encourage
others to do the same so there's a
process of governments coming together
and sharing that knowledge and
supporting each other to to be more
effective in measuring progress great
thank you
so the next question is how can data for
development be more inclusive how do
projects like the inclusive data charter
plan to address this mmm-hmm I think
this is I think this is a really
interesting question because inclusion
of different groups this is one area
where we're making a lot of progress and
sort of a lot of it is to do with norms
and people's attitudes about what's
acceptable in society but if essentially
there are different reasons that people
are sort of invisible to the system one
is a lack of capacity and a lack of
money to capture information about their
lives in some cases it's a little
convenient to not have information about
people either because you don't want to
spend money to improve their
circumstances or in some cases
sadly different groups have reason to
hide you know so groups that fear
persecution or groups that aren't
treated well within their countries and
not necessarily one
to be captured so this is an area that
there's a sort of technical component
there's a policy component and there's a
sort of social justice and advocacy
component so we're interested in all of
those different areas and we're working
at different levels with a number of
different partners to kind of push the
idea that everybody has a right to be
included in data and everybody should
have a right to benefit from social
progress so what we don't want to see is
countries getting better but people who
are the most disadvantaged being left
behind the sustainable development goals
call for the most disadvantaged in
society to be helped first but of course
if we don't know who those people are
how can we help them so we're we're very
keen to see that happen and the
inclusive data charter underpins that
from an advocacy and from a technical
perspective absolutely so the next
question is what are some of the
challenges that nonprofits face around
advanced cloud computing so I can start
with that great thank you so as I
mentioned before two of the challenges
that we've identified that nonprofits
faced are well one financial and two
technical financial being around the
budget the resources to finance a short
term data analytics project medium term
long term really any data analytics
project because once you get past the
storage point and you start you know
querying and developing custom models
with machine learning it can get a
little costly in the long term for
nonprofit organizations so you know
dressing that financial barrier is very
important especially at the get go
because you know program like data
solutions for a change can actually help
nonprofits create a proof point kind of
like a you know a pitch or demonstrative
proposal that then can rally additional
support then help to you know get that
additional support for you know budget
and and financial resources I'd say on
the other side of things is the
technical expertise so do they have
experience working with data analytics
you know increasingly more nonprofits
are looking to get involved I mean for
all the reasons that you know Jenny
mentioned before around data for
development and opportunities to close
informational gaps so the question is is
there someone actually embedded within a
nonprofit team that is a date
scientist or you know has some knowledge
of sequel and also actually connects to
the financial challenge too because yep
actually having a fully staffed data
scientist nevermind to the data science
team can be also costly so you know
again making resources available for you
know self-training or even you know
mentorship also looking at organizations
across different disciplines as well to
see you know if one nonprofit for
example has the financial resources
they've secured the budget maybe they
can partner with another organization
that does have a data scientist and can
work together on a collaborative project
which is actually another area to that
it says that I've heard from nonprofits
it can be an area a challenge area for
them and that is working effectively
with you know other nonprofit
organizations and kind of coming
together when they have shared goals
because you know each organization you
know is motivated by their own you know
their own mission and their own
particular KPIs but to come together and
kind of you know come to those KPIs
together I think what further further
their mission holistically and also help
to achieve these goals at scale anything
that you'd like to add from yeah I think
I'd like to add we took a lot in our
organization about interoperability and
how to make things work together I think
there's a sort of sense of interoperable
people are needed here as well you know
too often you have people you have
technical skills but they're not really
integrated into wider teams and they
don't necessarily know how to work
across different organizations so
encouraging that sort of dialogue and
for the people with technical expertise
to be better about talking about these
issues and identifying problems and the
people who don't have it to be better at
kind of understanding what is needed
even if they can't technically implement
it is really important so I think sort
of advice technical support knowing that
there's somebody to ask for help when
you need it is really important it's not
that everybody has to become a coder
it's that people need to know who to ask
and when absolutely yeah I also add that
into Jenni's point to you relationship
building is really important
you know at the the data for development
festival that was an amazing experience
which brought to you know brought
together many organizations many people
from across the world working across
several disciplines it was great just to
have everyone in the room learn more
about their work and also just kick off
conversations on how we can you know
work better together and so I met a lot
of people there I attended personally
it's a great experience as I mentioned
before also very much looking forward to
the UN world data forum another great
opportunity to again like bring a
variety of different people together
from different disciplines and from
various countries across the world yeah
absolutely so the the last question that
we have here is you know what kind of
expertise do you need to get involved
with data for good I think that this is
this is an interesting question because
there's so many to also Jenny's point
interoperability there's so many
different skill sets that can contribute
to you know this movement and to this
work so for me I I personally don't have
a technical background but I would say
that you know critical thinking is
something that is supremely important
and problem-solving abilities as well
looking holistically you know out a
problem looking at the quote unquote big
picture but also willing to dive a
little bit deeper into the details that
are captured by by data and also I'd add
storytelling is important so before I
mentioned you know data visualization
visualize 2030
and also the importance of being able to
develop these custom reports it's not
just for the sake of developing reports
it's about telling a particularly
persuasive story and to onboard
you know stakeholders or other partners
or actually you know tell make an
effective pitch you know why we need to
focus on this particular area versus
another so again implementing these
data-driven decisions with an eye
towards you know other skill sets again
like along the lines of storytelling
yeah I think that's absolutely true one
of the problems of this area is that
data is complex technology is complex it
it confuses people whereas kind of we
need to give vaccinations to a child is
gives you to understand we need to feed
people is easy to understand so there's
a challenge to us to communicate why
this matters but in terms of people
interested to get involved there are so
many ways and they
a number of different organizations that
allow you to kind of donate your time
without needing to be physically in the
space to do things like playing games
that help identify malaria through
looking at different sort of sequences
to mapping different areas you know one
of the big problems is that there are
whole parts of the world that aren't
mapped and could do with being you know
better captured so you can if you only
have a few hours a week and you're
interested in this then there are many
different ways to get involved yeah and
to add opportunities I mean beyond its
kind of like area of expertise question
and there's also opportunities to
participate in the data for good
movement through cadigal and also just
learn more about data science so kaggle
for those unfamiliar with the platform
is a community platform to actually
problem-solve
together to use their workbench solution
of kernels to analyze data sets and
actually you know show your work so to
speak as you go through that analysis
and also be able to engage with other
members who are participating on the
platform kaggle also launched a series
of data science for good events so if
you are a data scientist or versioning
data scientist you can explore those
challenges and kind of put your skills
to work there too another organization
that we have worked with in the past and
actually presented webinar with
previously back in June or July is data
kind so data kind they do a lot of great
work they have a large last night check
like over 18,000 volunteers as part of
their network and they actually match
pro bono data scientists analysts
designers etc with mission driven
organizations that are facing a
particulate data or a particular data
analytics challenge so I think that's
another great way to to get involved and
the partnership of course yes the
partnership is the partnership is
focused on organizations so I would
encourage anyone working institutionally
he wants to get involved but as I
mentioned many of our partners so if you
come to WWE - for SDGs
or then you can see all of our partners
and a number of them focus on individual
and how they can get involved yeah
absolutely wonderful well thank you
again for your time today it was great
to have this opportunity have Jenny be
present and share the work that she's
doing with the global partnership for
sustainable development data and also
touch on the initiatives that we
launched recently again those are data
solutions for change for nonprofits and
visualize 2030 a data storytelling
contest for students at the higher ed
level so with that
stay tuned for the next session and
continue to keep up with cloud on-air
webinars thank you thank you